Mi inspiración viene de problemas de mi vida cotidiana.
Por ejemplo,
una vez necesitaba un traje para ir a una convención de cómics,
pero no quería gastar demasiado dinero,
así que hice mis propias...
corona y falda luminosas.
(Risas)
Otra vez,
estaba devastada porque habían sacado mi juego favorito para móviles,
Flappy Bird,
lo habían sacado del app store.
(Risas)
Así que me enfrenté al dilema
de no actualizar el teléfono o nunca volver a jugar Flappy Bird.
(Risas)
Poco feliz con ambas opciones,
hice lo único que tenía sentido para mí.
Hice una versión física de Flappy Bird
que nunca pudieran sacar del app store.
(Risas)
(Música)
(Pitido)
(Risas)
Algunos amigos eran bastante adictos al juego también,
así que los invité a jugar.
(Video) Amiga: ¡Ah!
(Risas)
(Video) Amiga: ¿Qué diablos?
Y me dijeron que era tan exasperante como el juego original.
(Risas)
Así que subí una demo de este proyecto
y, para mi sorpresa, se hizo viral.
Tuvo unas dos millones de vistas en solo unos días.
(Risas)
Y lo más interesante son los comentarios de la gente.
Mucha gente quería hacer su propia versión,
o preguntarme cómo lo hice.
Esto confirmó mi idea de que mediante un proyecto creativo,
podemos enseñar ingeniería.
Con el dinero ganado con el video viral,
pudimos hacer que los estudiantes en el aula
construyeran su propio juego.
Aunque fue bastante desafiante,
aprendieron muchos conceptos nuevos de ingeniería y programación.
Y todos estaban ansiosos por aprender para poder terminar el juego también.
(Risas)
Y antes de la caja de Flappy Bird,
tuve la idea de usar proyectos de ingeniería creativa en la enseñanza.
Cuando enseñaba en la primaria,
le pedimos a los estudiantes crear un robot con un kit de tecnología estándar.
Y noté que muchos parecían aburrirse.
Luego algunos empezaron a decorar
sus robots con papeles.
Y luego se sumaron otros,
y así se interesaron por el proyecto.
Así que empecé a buscar formas más creativas
de presentar tecnología a los estudiantes.
Encontré que muchos kits de tecnología disponibles en las escuelas
parecen un poco intimidantes.
Están hechos de partes plásticas que no pueden personalizarse.
Además de eso, todos son muy caros,
cuesta cientos de dólares cada kit.
No es muy asequible para la mayoría de los presupuestos de las aulas.
Como no encontré nada,
decidí crear algo sola.
Empecé con papel y tela.
Después de todo, todos jugamos con eso desde niños,
y son bastante baratos
y pueden encontrarse en cualquier parte de la casa.
Hice el prototipo de un proyecto
en el que los estudiantes pueden crear una criatura luminosa
con telas y ojos de plástico.
Se ayudaban unos a otros en clase,
se reían y discutían el proyecto.
Y, más importante,
podían poner su propia creatividad en el proyecto.
Y dado el éxito de este proyecto,
seguí creando más proyectos de ingeniería
para desafiar a mis estudiantes.
Y empecé a llevar estos talleres afuera de la escuelas
y a la comunidad.
Y ocurrió algo muy interesante.
Noté que muchas personas de orígenes muy diversos
empezaron a venir a nuestros talleres.
Y, sobre todo,
había muchas más mujeres y minorías de lo que esperaba,
y eso no se ve generalmente en los talleres de ingeniería.
Vean este informe de empleados de una tecnológica grande en 2016.
Las mujeres son el 19 % de la fuerza laboral en tecnología.
Y las minorías subrepresentadas son solo el 4 %.
Esta estadística puede resultar familiar
para alguien que frecuenta clubes de robótica de secundaria,
o clases de ingeniería en la universidad.
Pero hay una amplia gama de problemas
que contribuyen a la falta de diversidad en el área de tecnología.
Quizá una solución podría ser
presentar la tecnología a los estudiantes con proyectos creativos.
No digo que esto podría resolverlo todo,
pero podría presentar la tecnología
a personas que en principio no estarían interesadas en eso
debido a la forma de presentar y enseñar el tema en la escuela.
¿Cómo empezamos a cambiar la percepción de la tecnología?
La mayoría de los estudiantes piensa que es aburrida o poco acogedora,
por eso yo siempre he diseñado proyectos siguiendo tres principios.
Primero, debe tener un piso bajo,
o sea, debe ser fácil de comenzar el proyecto.
Vean este tutorial.
El primer proyecto que le pedimos a los estudiantes que aprendan
es hacer un circuito en papel.
Y pueden ver, no llevar demasiado tiempo en aprender,
y es bastante fácil incluso para principiantes.
Y tener un piso bajo significa también que eliminamos la barrera financiera
que impide que la gente termine un proyecto.
Así, con papel, cinta de cobre, una lamparita y una batería,
la gente puede terminar este proyecto por menos de un dólar.
El segundo principio, es tener un techo alto.
Es decir, tener mucho espacio para crecer,
a los estudiantes se los desafía todo el tiempo.
Al principio puede ser solo una criatura iluminada,
pero luego se le pueden añadir sensores y microcontroladores,
y empezar a programar la criatura para interactuar con su entorno.
(Risas)
Y finalmente,
el tercer principio es la personalización.
Esto significa que podemos hacer este proyecto relevante para todos.
Esa es la belleza de usar materiales cotidianos;
es muy fácil de personalizar usando papel y tela.
Así que incluso si no les gusta Flappy Bird,
pueden hacer su propio juego.
(Video) Estudiante: Nuestro juego es sobre Justin Bieber,
porque condujo a alta velocidad,
y el objeto es impedir que lo atrape el organismo de control...
(Risas)
(Video) Estudiante: Sí, pero está cambiando así que...
somos parte de su pandilla.
(Risas)
Gracias.
(Aplausos)